hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
1611 precisely excellent 165 165 165.
all right no need to discuss the
primeness of that no we don't uh it's
actually exact 50 episodes to the
episode uh past one that we will be
discussing today when we maybe not for
the first time but for the most
extensive time discussed Miss discs and
Mal information which we'll be coming
back to today in part because of some of
the latest revelations in the Twitter
files
excellent we're also going to be talking
about
um
the nature of respiratory viruses
pandemics and iatrogenic harm which we
will Define when we get to that section
and we'll be uh reading a few short
excerpts from a theologian a German
Theologian who was a chaplain in the
German Army in World War one and later
sent missives into Germany from America
during World War II to try to wake the
German people up
excellent I am looking forward to this I
do have to say to our audience we are
once again working uh Zach is looking
out for us remotely but we are running
the podcast ourselves if I appear to be
distracted momentarily I'm just trying
to make sure that there is nothing I
need to know about what's going uh right
or wrong and uh I should comment we
didn't mention uh an idea that Zach had
before he left was this light bulb which
is a bit meta I mean
in any case let us know what you think
of it
um all right uh uh we have
also I just launched right in without
saying you're Brett Weinstein all right
Brett Weinstein and I am Dr Heather
hiing and let's do a couple of a little
bit of uh Logistics up front thanking
you all for your support in various ways
and telling you where else you can find
us and our sponsors and then we'll get
right into some of that Mystic mail
information that uh you have all come to
enjoy so much so
um once again this week we'll not be
doing a q a uh next week we'll be back
same time same place and we will do a q
a and maybe maybe I'm not promising but
maybe we'll make it a little longer
since we will have missed two weeks in a
row apologies for that I know a lot of
people really appreciate being able to
ask us questions and we were in a
situation this week when we were able to
be asked questions
um with a live audience and it was just
it's just so wonderful to remember what
that's like yeah so really uh it was a
reminder of just what an awesome
experience that is yeah indeed so uh we
will be back with the Q a next week
uh you can find you can find my writing
weekly at Natural Selections my sub
stack this week I republished
a piece that was originally published in
the essay Anthology iconoclast uh it's
called me she he they and it's an
exploration of sex and gender and
transness and specifically also
non-binariness and whether or not that
makes any sense at all as an identity
spoiler alert no it does not uh I'm I'm
proud of this essay and a lot of people
have truly enjoyed it so I encourage you
to go there if that is one of the topics
that you are
um interested in or thinking it is a
harbinger of the Apocalypse one of the
horsemen I think it is and I do think
that we can reverse at least that part
of it and maybe once we turn one of the
horses around maybe we can get them all
turned yeah we can just be done with
harbingers all together whatever
harbatures are yeah whatever a Harbinger
is any Harbinger in the storm no maybe
that's how that works probably not
um so we are supported by you and we
appreciate you uh subscribing to the
channel liking uh whole videos that you
find here on YouTube and on Odyssey and
on Spotify and if you're listening only
in whatever form you are taking in your
podcast Please Subscribe if you like the
channel like uh share videos share Clips
which you can find Clips um Dark Horse
podcast Clips on both YouTube and
odyssey as well and odyssey is where the
live chat is happening if you're tuning
in you can also comment there's no
reason just to shake your fist idly at
your screen you can tell us
yes you can yeah that suggests that we
manage look at the comments which we
don't sometimes we do but
um but uh but commenting does um
in a fair World commenting would help
with the algorithms that would then put
what we're doing in front of more people
but um it's patently not fair in that
way so I don't know that your comments
do but
um they say that if there isn't any sort
of shadowy stuff going on behind the
scenes that the more comments the more
likely uh the work is to get spread yes
in our case we know that YouTube is
there that they shake their fists at the
screen and then they start pressing
buttons they do sabotage our content
which is um you know I can't say we
appreciate it because I know that we
don't but uh we also seemed so far not
to have been able to stop them from
doing that yep
um all right uh so uh also we encourage
you to join uh one of our patreons on
both of them you can get access to our
wonderful Discord server where you can
join conversations in a variety of
formats on a variety of topics across um
a whole swath of humanity uh who are
enjoying being there and doing things
like happy hour and karaoke and book
clubs and at my patreon you can join a
monthly private q a that we do together
the last Sunday of every month and the
first usually first Saturdays and
Sundays of every month you have
conversations one of which you just
finished uh for the month uh from at
your patreon indeed quite provocative
um and uh actually some good stuff may
have come out of it so anyway it was uh
it was a good conversation and people
who are looking for a good group of
folks who are actually interested in
figuring out how the world might be
improved it's a great place to uh
to come join us that's fabulous
all right and of course we do have
sponsors we pick and choose our sponsors
carefully and so if we are reading ads
as we do three at the top of every hour
you can be sure that we have vetted
these
um these companies and actually are
speaking for them foreign
our first sponsor this week is mind
Bloom mind Bloom is a leader in at-home
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of scientifically robust medicine with
clinically guided support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being if you or someone you
love is struggling with mental health
issues those issues May well Loom large
in your life there is no
one-size-fits-all solution but you know
that you or your loved one needs
something that will help achieve a real
and Lasting breakthrough
maybe it's time for you to check out a
guided ketamine Therapy Program from
mind Bloom mind Bloom could be your next
and most successful chapter in mental
health and well-being mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes at lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience to begin you take
mind Bloom's online assessment and
schedule a video consult with a licensed
clinician to determine if mind Bloom is
right for you if approved you'll discuss
your health history and goals for mental
health treatment with your clinician to
tell your mind Bloom regimen mind Bloom
will send you a kit in the mail complete
with medicine treatment materials and
tips for getting the most out of your
experience after only four sessions 89
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in their symptoms of
depression and anxiety as one client
reports on their site quote I thought I
was broken now the light inside me is
growing stronger every day
let mind Bloom guide you into a better
chapter of mental health and well-being
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners 100 off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Dark Horse and use promo
code Darkhorse at checkout go to
mindbloom.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse for 100 off your first
succession program today that's mind
Bloom
m-i-n-d-b-l-o-o-m.com
darkhorsepromocode Darkhorse
okay our second sponsor today is
American Heart for gold
if you listen to Dark Horse which if
you're listening to this ad presumably
you do then you likely know just how
incompetent and unstable many of our
institutions are becoming inflation is
at its highest level in 40 years
interest rates are Sky High we are
caught between runaway inflation and
recession and our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all of this
threatens businesses jobs and retirement
funds finding ways to secure your nest
egg and insulate your wealth is more
important than ever in adding precious
metals to your assets is a great way to
stabilize your Investments and protect
yourselves yourself financially or
yourselves if you're if you're they them
um American
okay if you're a couple or a family that
makes a lot more sense I guess couples
families are they then yes couples and
families are dating them so they're much
more likely to try to protect their
assets by uh investing in Precious
Metals which we recommend American Heart
for gold is a precious metals dealer
that can help you do just that American
Heart for gold helps individuals and
families see that's right protect their
wealth by diversifying with precious
metals they make it simple and easy to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts with physical gold and silver
with one short phone call you can have
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door or inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rate from the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they will give you up to five
thousand dollars of free silver on your
first qualifying order
contact American Heart for gold today by
visiting the link in the episode
description below or call
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
once more that's
866-828-1117 to get on the phone with
the people at American Hartford gold who
can help you get actual precious metals
in your portfolio or text Darkhorse to
important to remember how much of a
better investment physical gold and
silver is than mental gold and silver
which you know yeah got tons of that
yeah as much as you want really all you
can eat yeah okay our final sponsor this
week is Vivo barefoot shoes made for
feet everyone should try these shoes
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of feet not vivos vivos are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them and words are spreading yes
absolutely some of the best yeah
um we sometimes get asked by people who
come up to us and want to know whether
vivos are as good as we say and they
really are here at Dark Horse we love
these shoes
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you are
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they are fantastic our
feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively affected foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo
barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're a certified B
Corp that is pioneering regenerative
business practices their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials and that
with the aim to protect the natural
world so you can run wild upon it go to
Vivo barefoot.com and use Darkhorse 15
to get an exclusive 15 off additionally
all new customers get a 100 day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's Vivo Barefoot
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the
code darkhorse15 at checkout
laughs
there it is there it is we transitioned
we transitioned out of ads yes back into
the main part of the podcast that's a
totally standard kind of transition yeah
the kind that is actually possible in
reality land yes which is where we hope
to where we're broadcasting from that's
right we are here talking to you from
reality land hopefully you're there too
okay uh so we wanted to start by talking
by returning to a topic we have we have
discussed many times uh but uh as I as I
mentioned we uh we talked about in depth
50 episodes ago
uh on episode
115 in February of 2022
and Miss dis and malinformation but
maybe you want to introduce it given
because we're talking about it because
of some of the stuff that's happened
this week with the Twitter files yeah
Congress yeah we have new Twitter files
and even more importantly we had the
testimony of Michael schellenberger and
Matt taibi to the House of
Representatives
um where uh it was a remarkable hearing
I actually recommend that people go back
and just start listening uh to what is
said it is so amazing in Matt taibi's
case we have one of the most decorated
journalists of our era being slandered
as if he was some sort of uh Pretender a
grifter or not a journalist at all the
so-called journalist is in fact what he
was accused of being
and it's just what planet is this from
but nonetheless um the hearing it seems
to be from planet Blue from planet blue
it seems to be somehow somehow the party
that you and I remember as The Party The
anti-war Party
um and the party that would defend
liberal principles like free speech
um is now the party attacking these very
things it's the party of this newfangled
racism it's hard to believe what's
happened but nonetheless we are where we
are and uh so Matt and Michael
testified about what they have seen in
the Twitter files which are basically
files that Elon Musk has made available
to select journalists in order to reveal
what has taken place behind the scenes
with respect to the control of
information and the central feature of
what was revealed in the most recent
Twitter files and in the testimony of
Matt and Michael to the house was the
massive network of collusion between
various pieces of our Security State and
the tech platforms to suppress various
viewpoints and
I was particularly struck to see a
discussion you know in in the Congress
uh by by Matt of Miss dis and Mal
information right Mystic and
malinformation is something you and I
have been trying to raise the alarm
about since episode 115 back in February
of 2022 and the context is nothing if
not alarming and I was a little bit
shocked to see that the full weight of
it actually had not yet
um become visible in the context of the
Twitter file so
missed this and Mal information you will
all remember are three categories that
were seen together I think for the first
time
on February 7th of 2022. uh yeah let's
show your screen if I can remember how
to do that
so this is this is uh a bulletin from
the Department of Homeland Security uh
from exactly as you said February 7 2022
and we showed exactly this as well in
episode 115 in February of 2022 stating
that they have issued a national
terrorism advisory system bulletin
suggesting
um and and as to why they're doing that
um because they're you know there are
continuing threats against uh against
the Homeland apparently right and uh and
and I'm not you may have to undo my
screen in order for me to get to the
right place to to show but you were
about to Define uh the terms but I think
we can also
um
we can also get there directly if you
want to start defining some Mal
information as I yes you will all those
of you who watched episode 115 will be
reminded that misinformation is
information that is incorrect but
accidentally
um
there you go
I'm going to interrupt you for a moment
and say so the Department of Homeland
Security Site which we were just on the
bulletin from February 7 2022 links to a
missed us and malinformation site here
exactly this and we'll put this in the
show notes uh which is at the cyber
security and infrastructure Security
Agency branch of the federal government
of the United States and here they have
terms to know some tactics have foreign
influence they specify here included
leveraging misinformation disinformation
malinformation definitions for each or
below if we just read these or you want
to Define them well I'm a little
concerned because I know that some of
their sites they have modified these
definitions perhaps in part because we
called attention to what they were up to
these are these have actually remained
the same they're remain the same okay
even even though this this site looks
very different uh and uh and it appears
to be living in a different place
uh you can't get there the same way you
could get there 13 months ago but the
definitions that they've they've used
here the same ones that we shared in
February of 2022. all right so
misinformation is false but not created
or shared with the intention of causing
harm
disinformation is deliberately created
to mislead harm or manipulate a person
social group organization or country and
Mal information is based on fact but
used out of context to mislead harm or
manipulate an example of malinformation
is editing a video to remove important
contacts to harm or mislead so that that
is one sentence that I'm I don't think
was in the original yeah I don't think
it was an original and there's been a
lot of uh skullduggery behind the scenes
including the deleting of uh what
amounts to evidence of this uh extra
constitutional behavior on the part of
the Department of Homeland Security but
the upshot is this before we get to the
upshot because that is the that is the
um the final bit here can we just spend
some time talking about the mistus and
malinformation yes I I want to I want to
go through the taxonomy misinformation
one of the things that we said in the
episode and we'll we'll share actually
the clip that I think the 25 minute clip
in which we talked about it a year ago
is that actually in education
and when you teach at least uh if you if
you're teaching well if you're actually
trying to get your students to be able
to go out into the world and assess what
is true and what is not and uh and have
a response when people are trying to
manipulate them is that you provided to
them forms of Miss dis and
malinformation in order to allow them to
learn how to recognize it when it comes
at them yeah I would say it differently
I would say they have gone out of their
way to formalize things as if they are
um a threat that are actually a normal
part of various kinds of discourse
comedy teaching Etc
misinformation
errors disinformation intentional errors
malinformation things that are not in
error but that might lead to the
distrust of
the government distrust of things like
vaccine safety now the
there are two parts to this
um yeah there are two parts
to the problem here and one of them was
clearly outlined in the hearings by
Michael and Matt
that is the Draconian nature of these
definitions with respect to a systematic
campaign of uh propaganda and censorship
right they fully recognize the horror of
your government defining things like
information that is based in fact but
causes distrust of the government
entities themselves to declare that
worthy of some sort of control is a
unconstitutional and B very troubling
because it is part and parcel of uh
propaganda and censorship which are at
the core of tyrannical state power
what they did not say so we do have a
few more things to say about this if you
if you want to go ahead
um one of the things that we talked
about
um
a year ago but did not actually share a
link to and we're going to this time
share a link this is um you can actually
show my screen again this is a PDF from
the same the same cluster of sites of
government sites in which they give
advice to organizations or people who
might want to control Miss dis and
malinformation and they call this the
rumor control page startup guide
and we did talk about this some uh a
year ago but they again have missed this
and Mal information defined this time
with handy little infographics in which
the bullhorn is spreading out true
things that the government wishes would
not be said and that is Mal information
and if you come down and and try to
learn what is it what should you do what
does the government want you to do if
you think that you have determined that
there is some misdis or mal information
out there well here how do you
communicate effectively on a rumor
control page remember the government
thinks that rumor control pages are good
because Rumors in this in this taxonomy
are bad things you know errors
intentional errors or things that the
government doesn't want you talking
about or knowing uh well uh you could
preemptively debunk or pre-bunk was the
phrase that uh that we found amusing a
year ago because what are they talking
about lead with the truth not the rumor
keep it simple hey they've got a light
bulb look at that and be consistent in
the types of misinformation
disinformation and malinformation
narratives and activities that you
debunk you know don't be too much of a
generalist stay in your lane so
wait wait go back
um I would just want to point out that
lead with the truth doesn't mean lead
with the truth it means lead with that
fraction of the truth that does not
cause distrust of the government right
now I just want to point out as a
patriotic American how unpatriotic this
is this is a violation of arguably the
most Central principle at the heart of
the free West the ability to discuss
that which is true
especially when it involves things that
cause the government to be untrustworthy
and therefore need to be corrected
through the natural mechanisms of
democracy so I will say you said uh I
want to point out as a patriotic
American just how unpatriotic this is I
would also like to point out as a
Scientific American just how
unscientific this is okay and Scientific
American doesn't mean anything in
particular except it used to be a
Popular Science magazine of some repute
but has since fallen into the
ideological Rabbit Hole uh but this is
the opposite of of how one understands
the world scientifically because okay
government defined truth oh wait no
please don't because you keep on getting
it wrong and science does right like
science is a process by which we
constantly refine our understanding and
hopefully get closer and closer and
closer to a true understanding of what
is actually going on in the universe and
on balance over time if you take the
long time Horizon we certainly do get
there but any given change may have
actually moved us backwards you can't
know in the moment and we have seen in
the last three years of this unending uh
fear-mongering Stars cov2 landscape that
we live in now and will forever probably
um
that when the government changes its
opinions as to what is true or what is
the right policy or what it is that
you're allowed to talk about they always
kind of
vaguely wave their arms and say well of
course the science has changed and in no
case so far that I have seen them do
this and that we have talked about this
has have we found or have they supplied
any evidence that the science just
changed and of course the science change
isn't what they mean what they're
suggesting is that the scientific
evidence uh has is now pointing in a
different direction which would be
fantastic if that was actually what was
going on but in fact either they have
lost control of the narrative and they
have to admit something they didn't want
to admit before or they are simply
changing up what it is that they want
you to believe now and in neither that
case nor the former case are they
actually going to provide any evidence
because you know you wouldn't understand
or something like that yes and it uh
eliminates the natural remedies should
government fail in its attempt to do
science or to Foster science certainly
the way we would find that out and do
something about it would be to discuss
the failure of our government with
respect to a scientific question and if
you're not allowed to talk about things
that contravene the government's current
scientific perspective then that can't
be done so this basically assumes that
the government will be right it is a
religious position that they are selling
the public exactly remember when uh
Facebook's fact-checking arm PolitiFact
declared you and Robert Malone uh
purveyors of their worst level of
unfactiness pant liar liar pants on fire
uh for uh claiming a few things
including uh that SARS Kobe 2 may have
actually leaked from a lab that earned
their liar liar pants on fire rating
because that was not true then
but it maybe later became a little bit
less true because or a little bit more
true because they rescinded their rating
without saying anything about it and
said no maybe we don't know well let's
just look at what's happened now that
the uh Washington Post is able to talk
about the probability that this virus
emerged from a lab you and the public
are clearly licensed to talk about it
which is basically synonymous with
saying that the government has dictated
when you can talk about this which is
obviously a violation of the First
Amendment right you're no longer guilty
of Mal information if you talk about it
but we will let you know when you are
Mal information
terrorism I should point out we haven't
gotten there yet remember
um right
um so just one more thing from this page
um they offer a rumor control checklist
if you are an organization or a person
who wants to go into rumor control uh
mode and fight the good fight with the
government against Miss dis and
malinformation here are some things that
they suggest you consider and if most of
your answers are yes you're probably in
a good position to put up one of these
rumor control checklists rumor control
uh sites of your own
is the narrative
um around a contentious or disputed
topic where information is changing or
not widely known
it's a good chance you should probably
fact check that if the if the
information is changing
okay our multiple narratives or
artifacts converging into a single
narrative or conspiracy
well look if there's a lot of stories
and we're getting a refinement as to
what we think is true that's a good sign
that you should put something up to
pre-bunk or prior or what it was like
debunk in advance or in advance pre-buck
they went like pre-pre-buck I can't
remember which ones are Preposterous
jokes and which ones were official
proposals it may be rebunk rebuke yeah
no but they they asked they suggested
that you should debunk and pre-bunk
and then if the narrative or artifact
focuses on upcoming major Milestones or
events where early fact-checking could
proactively disrupt the spread
so major Milestones or events they don't
say anything about whether or not those
major Milestones or events are true not
true good bad and they're like we know
that the government has some idea about
what it does and does not want you to be
resisting here but there's nothing in
here about what is actually true
because because if there were then that
would take that would pull the rug out
from under this plan so now you would
like to come back to
um yes
the fact of the government being
involved in a massive propaganda
campaign in which they are going to sell
us narratives that contravene the truth
and they are going to silence voices
that point this out is bad enough
but it becomes 10 times worse when they
do so under the guise of preventing a
kind of terrorism and what most people
do not understand and what was not
mentioned in these hearings as far as I
know
is the fact that when they say Miss dis
and Mal information are a form of
terrorism they are saying something with
absolutely profound legal consequences
or I should probably say extra legal
consequences because of changes that
were made to the structure of our laws
under the bush and Obama administrations
when the executive branch of which the
Department of Homeland Security is a
part the declares somebody a terrorist
it triggers all kinds of Provisions that
in the Panic after 9 11 we allowed to be
installed into law things that
effectively end your constitutional
rights so it is important that people
understand we presumably by their
definitions have been guilty of
spreading Mal information in this
podcast because what we're telling you
is that your government is now behaving
as a rogue state that it is declaring
people terrorists who are doing nothing
but speaking the truth we don't know
that it has done that we don't know that
it has done it but the point is they've
set out a definition and the definition
involves true things that cause distrust
and this is something that should cause
you to distrust your government it's
also true so the point is by using that
term they're not just saying Mal
information is bad they are saying Mal
information meets a technical standard
that then causes you to lose your rights
and the most important thing about this
is It's not that they they there is no
obligation that they tell you that you
have triggered this provision in the law
you do not have the right to challenge
it in a court you do not even know that
it has happened and so we are talking
about a level of tyranny well beyond
propaganda and censorship and that is
something that should truly alarm us so
I really hope that we will
start to to understand their private
language right the executive branch has
powers that they are not supposed to
have that have not been tested by a
court and those Powers have everything
to say about our information environment
what we are allowed to discover who we
are allowed to listen to and
um it really it could not be a a more
frightening turn of events I'm glad that
we are finally having a conversation at
the level of uh Congressional hearings
in which we're talking about Mal
information but let's not underrate the
danger of of that provision
indeed
all right is that where you wanted to I
think so this section all right
actually there is one more thing I
wanted to say about it
um
actually I'll save it for later sorry
I'm uh I I think that's a good place to
leave it for now
all right
so we also wanted to talk about uh the
nature of respiratory disease pandemics
and iatrogenic harm
this is prompted by a excellent piece on
a substant called Bad catitude by an
anonymous scholar writer
who goes by gato Malo
in which he writes I assume it's a he I
think it has to be a he because
otherwise it would be Gata Mala maybe
maybe not maybe he's misgendering
himself in the sub stack I don't think I
don't think that's how it works anyway
yeah
um I think all cats are male in Spanish
you know it's not even binary it's like
monetary
oh where we landed I don't know no this
this is fine I'd rather land here than a
lot of the places that seem to be where
people are spending time yeah I agree
yeah
um
so uh this the piece is called and and
we'll link to it uh in in the show notes
the greater than against bad attitude
with two T's like cat and attitude is a
portmanteau work work
is not a word no
it's called the greatest lie told during
covid and the one they will undoubtedly
try to tell again
so the LIE is as gato Malo argues in
this piece pandemics are dangerous to
Modern societies
now that's going to sound like an
extraordinary thing to call a lie isn't
it um how could they not be we all know
we all know of pandemics like the one
we're supposedly still living in
um
and the Spanish Flu uh and how you know
how completely dangerous they are but
but he he lays it out and I'm going to
lay out some of it and again I recommend
that you read the piece but let's just
lay out a few of the a few of the pieces
here what do we actually know
um well one of one of actually before I
before I lay it out in an organized way
one of the
um past pandemics of that last hundred
years uh that he points to is the Hong
Kong flu uh in 1968-69 uh which I had
actually not heard of except that we
were both born in 1969 and your mother
actually had it when she was pregnant
with you that's right right and that may
explain everything it may explain
everything absolutely
um but it was you know it was it was it
was pretty bad people were taking it
very seriously and yet what happened uh
near the near the Ender in the like in
the middle of
um of the Hong Kong flues but so-called
Hong Kong flu uh being one of the worst
pandemics in America well Woodstock
happened right you know instead of the
response that we had during covid which
is shut down everything and um instill
fear in the hearts and minds of everyone
that you can possibly instill fear in we
let we let that's that's a terrible way
to put it but you know the the American
government and the American people uh
apparently never considered or if they
ever considered it never got past some
very small meetings
um doing anything like disrupting
Society at the level that has happened
during coven Woodstock happened one of
the you know greatest known public
displays of sort of
um human extasis in the 20th century
right so
and what happened gosh well Woodstock
that's got to have been a super spreader
event well no it was fun right it was
fine so
um similarly as I was reading this piece
sort of before I lay out his argument
um he mentioned zika which was a virus
uh that shows up in South America as
something that causes if I remember
correctly micro encephaly uh in babies
born to mothers who exposed to zika
while they were pregnant and we were
about to go on our 11-week study abroad
with 30 students uh you know half of
whom were women and all of whom were
reproductive age and we had to we had to
we felt compelled we felt honor bound
and and that it was required of us to
talk carefully with all of them about
what this what we could tell about this
new emerging pathogen what the risks
were to them uh and
um to advise that if any of them were
actually thinking of you know getting
pregnant becoming mothers anytime soon
they should maybe considered not going
that it was you know that there there
seemed to be some kind of a some kind of
a latency and it was this emerging virus
we didn't know um but it was it was our
Our obligation to talk about what um
what that was and it seemed like it
might be something that would take over
the world and then it fizzled right like
people just stopped talking about it at
some point after some number of months
and this in part is the argument that
gato Malo is making that um these these
mostly
um
these these pandemics that we are told
to be terrified of
uh if there is no big governmental
response they tend to burn themselves
out
so I could build that in a little bit
yeah oh you're gonna do it about two
yeah that respiratory pathogens almost
never cause pandemics in the modern era
basically since penicillin that
penicillin and other antibiotics
depending on you know what the pathogen
is uh have uh have done a fantastic job
of controlling the kinds of things that
might once have actually done widespread
fast damage in human populations and
that is even when they appear to because
many maybe you want to actually maybe
you want to jump in here before I get
into the public policy measures so
effectively the argument is that there
is a trade-off things that spread highly
effectively aren't highly pathogenic
um or highly virulent and so
the point is yes things can spread
across civilization a respiratory virus
though requires you to as we've talked
about many times on Dark Horse it
requires you to be up and about in order
to do the spreading and therefore it
can't make you all that sick which means
it's not likely to be all that deadly
there are diseases that are exceptions
but they have other modes of
transmission and so so just to fill that
in if you if if you do not transmit
directly if the pathogen doesn't go from
host to host but uses a vector to get
between you something that is malaria
that is mosquito-borne for instance
mosquito Vector diseases like malaria
like yellow fever like West Nile like
Dengue may actually benefit from making
its host sick enough to be non-mobile
such that mosquitoes are better able to
find hosts and then carry them to other
not yet infected potential hosts not
only
um not able to move around but you know
let's take Dengue yeah uh the colloquial
name break bone fever yeah
um the reason because of the profound
pain in the bones in a it happens after
a person's been infected a second time
by Dengue
um so this is a
a complex phenomenon that involves
somebody who already has immunity which
the pathogen then utilizes but anyway
the point is oh you your bones feel like
they're broken well you're not very good
at swatting mosquitoes even if you know
you're lying flat right so anyway some
pathogens can be profoundly debilitating
and very dangerous and Dengue the second
time you get it is one of these
pathogens
um but and one at least one of the
species of malaria which there are four
right these these diseases can be they
can be very very uh very and they can
kill you and still win in at being the
disease that they are being the pathogen
that they are that causes the disease
whereas if you don't have
a vector or some other mechanism by
which uh to spread making your host very
very very sick so that they can't go out
and infect other people is an
evolutionary dead end for the pathogen
and so pathogens that do that won't
persist yeah
um the other thing to say and this is
proper context we've been fed and overly
simplistic model of all kinds of things
including the damage that comes from
pathogens for this entire pandemic one
of the things that happens even if you
had a comparatively High case fatality
rate in large measure what's happening
is those are its pulling deaths that
would occur soon so they happen sooner
than they might but the idea that we've
been sold is that somebody's life was
lost and that's not the right way to
think about it it's how many years of
life were lost right and which so you
might actually be able to see that if
you if you look at excess mortality for
you know five years before through 10
years after exactly see if you have less
than expected afterwards because you
some older people have already died a
year two three years before they might
have that is exactly right
um so anyway it's not it's not a simple
calculation and also if you were doing
something like comparing unknown Harms
from a transfection agent and you know
an untried gene therapy uh and a disease
with an unknown risk to human life
if the risk is to young people then the
number of years lost for every life lost
is huge right whereas when somebody is
dying of covid and they are at their
life expectancy or Beyond it they're
losing very few years and these things
should it's not a difficult thing to
calculate the amount of loss we just
refuse to do it because something
wanted us to think these were deaths as
if these people were going to live
forever uh you know absent the virus
when in fact what mostly happened was
people who were very old or quite sick
had some years potentially lost but uh
not a huge number
so the argument continues again this is
in the bad catitude sub stack piece that
I will link to that many public policy
measures like lockdowns and
um although this wasn't a public policy
measure this is a widespread medical
measure particularly in some places like
New York the use of ventilators
lockdowns ventilators
did more harm than good
and many if not most of
if not maybe even the vast majority of
covet deaths during covid are
attributable to what Brett was just
talking about with regard to hastening
the demise of someone who was already
near the end of their life which doesn't
make it a wonderful thing to have
happened but it's less tragic than when
a child dies or a young person dies
um
but even
um you know if we look at 2020 before
the the transfectionations before the
so-called vaccines are trotted out at
which point
um we have other reasons to um consider
what excess deaths are about uh the the
argument laid out here is that many of
the
um
many of the harms many of the excess
deaths and other injuries that people
were experiencing were iatrogenic and
iatrogenic means and I'm just going to
read exactly the definition uh that that
he writes in his book is relating to in
his book in his sub stack relating to
illness caused by medical examination or
treatment
so if what we have
are largely harms caused not by the
pathogen but by the treatment
brought on in order to treat the
pathogen then certainly it could have
been avoided and there's a lot of
evidence that comes in a variety of
forms in this in this piece including
for instance that Sweden which almost
uniquely in the west
responded very quickly very early in a
couple of ways but then mostly just let
its Society be and a lot of people in
the west were confused I mean I was
confused like wow that's that's amazing
what are they doing I would have
expected Sweden and all the rest of the
Scandinavian countries to be doing sort
of what the US is doing but more so and
the fact is that what they did worked
and what they did was not much they let
Society be right they let Society do
what it in what it was supposed to be
doing and
uh specifically ventilators in the
ventilators which were widespread in
icus in New York and not in several
other states uh correlate uh you you see
extremely high death rates During the
period when ventilarities were being
used on coveted patients and icus in New
York and not at the same time
controlling for almost everything except
the exact location in these other states
where ventilators weren't being used
that suggests that the ventilators were
the cause
um the primary cause rather than the
covid you have of course
um
sending coveted positive people into
Care Homes where you know Care Homes are
already people who are who are at risk
or because of um because of their age
because they are somewhat infirm because
they're not being allowed to go outside
because they're not moving much you send
covert positive people into Care Homes
you spread covid and some of those
people are not going to make it and
keeping people inside rather than
letting people go outside and be active
and be healthy and make D while the sun
shines and do all the things that we're
supposed to be doing outside of course
was another iatrogenic harm as a result
a nitrogenic harm from during covid
which can be attributed to not the virus
but the policy in response to the virus
and then we'll talk about Spanish Flu in
a moment but you have some things to say
yeah I have a number of things to say
here
one
there is a question
the deaths occurred as a result of
medical treatment that was a mistake or
it may have been a mistake I think the
ventilators for instance the ventilators
yes the ventilators for instance sending
sick people to Care Homes all of these
things had a negative impact well I was
I was just saying with regard to a
mistake I hope that the ventilator use
was a mistake I cannot fathom how
sending sick people into Care Homes ever
made yeah
the Striking thing about our Behavior at
a medical level during covid was that we
did essentially everything we shouldn't
have done and none of the things we
should have done right people should
have been outside we locked them inside
we took sick people and sent them to
places they would infect other
vulnerable people we hooked them up to
ventilators when the ventilators didn't
we turned up the pressure right we
denied them drugs that are safe and do
work
we gave them things Medical Treatments
that don't work and cause harm it's
across the board and I keep trying to
call attention to the unlikeliness of
you landing on every wrong answer that's
really improbable right
um so I don't know whether that is just
a matter of we have a few morons who
think upside down and land on the wrong
answer all the time and really all you
got to do to find out the right answers
do the opposite of whatever they say
that seems super unlikely but could be
but the point is
um we did all these things whatever
their nature they caused a lot of people
to die and then we counted them as Cova
deaths and so the counting them is covet
deaths then amped up the Panic help
Stoke fear right and the Panic then
Justified the Draconian measures that
were inflicted on us so again I don't
know
how this worked or why it happened but
gato malo's point is we inflicted this
harm on ourselves it caused a lot of
fear because it created numbers that
left the impression of an extremely
dangerous virus now of course you and I
believe that the virus is very
destructive but it doesn't have a high
case fatality rate and so the fear that
it was going to rob us of you know our
friends and relatives at some high rate
was always nonsense but we created this
um fictional pathogen that was doing
that and those had there been a force
behind the scenes that had been looking
for an excuse to increase its own power
to control the behavior of the
population what could be said where
people could go this became that excuse
and it deployed it at an incredible rate
the other thing from the points you've
uh you've highlighted so far that I
thought was very strong
in this piece was it suggests that in
some sense as bad as a disease that's
circulating in society is and I think we
underrate the harm of all the things
that circulate but as bad as they are
it may be that the best thing you can do
is as little as possible you can treat
the symptoms you can take you know basic
rational precautions you isolate very
sick people yeah if you're sick don't
make contact with other people wash your
hands these sorts of things you know you
can treat uh acute cases if you've got a
really good safe drug that seems to
prevent it transmission when one person
in the household gets it you could give
that drug to the others you know and
there are all sorts of basic things you
could do but the new virus is at the
moment to introduce other new medical
technology or is that not the moment
that's the amazing thing and uh the last
thing I want to say at this stage in the
discussion is
we have two basic models of medicine in
competition and I believe that we saw
something like a coup unfold by one
against the other during the covet
pandemic
the coup was by the public health
approach to the medical health approach
now
I certainly agree that there are
questions to be raised about public
health there are things that happen at
the population level that matter that
are not best addressed at the personal
level however personal medical health
with respect to illnesses that an
individual comes down with
are
comparatively well addressed from a
bottom-up approach that is to say
doctors seeing patients discovering what
works what doesn't work talking with
each other improving their own
techniques pooling their information
right that system but treating patients
as individuals right not as uh
temporarily disaggregated members of
some vague population doctors don't
treat populations doctors treat
individuals individuals and pools of
doctors get smarter because
a doctor who sees a pattern will discuss
that pattern with other doctors who will
decide whether they are seeing that
pattern and what it might mean that
emergent intelligence grows in medicine
and what has happened here is we have
decided instead that we what we want is
the highest quality information sourced
by the people in a position to see the
most who will then hand down the
information about the standard of care
and in this case they handed us every
wrong idea there was they did massive
harm whereas Dar and they and they and
they they hey they basically
um
they handcuffed the doctors who
otherwise would have done much better
and so anyway the comparison between a
bottom-up approach doctors seeing
patients and discovering what works
versus a top-down approach where Anthony
fauci tells you what he was given on the
tablets on the mountain and this thing
right there's no comparison between
these in terms of how much harm was
going to be done we tried during covid
we tried the Anthony fauci version and
we got an absolutely unmitigated
disaster we got a disaster that we
Amplified yes we did yeah we made it
worse every day week month year that we
continued to listen to
um the the public health
I don't even know what to call it
machine I guess at this point because
it's it's fundamentally doing the
opposite of what it should be doing so
what uh
might have been going on with Spanish
flu
this is 19 18 19
um
and is usually trotted out as the
example in the 20th century of like okay
but you know we had penicillin like what
why that that was huge and we obviously
can't afford another another Spanish flu
and uh and
um
here's the thinking and I will walk
through a little bit of
walk through a little bit of what
Guatemala says and then go to the paper
that he's he's citing here
apparently aspirin which was a
relatively new drug at the time and
seemed like a wonder drug
uh and but not much was known about the
dosing and high dosages of course now
we're understood to be toxic aspirin was
a primary drug used in the treatment of
Spanish flu
especially in the military
and
specifically Spanish Flu was
preferentially treated in many areas
with doses of aspirin between 8 and 31
grams per day eating 31 grams per day
today most aspirin is at 325 milligrams
it's a third of a gram
and the max dose recommended this is
from a 1977 FDA guideline I don't know
if the FDA ever made sense but it made
more sense then than it does now uh
presumably 1977 FDA guidelines they said
you know what about 4 000 milligrams
about four grams per day is really as
much as you can safely take and toxic
dose is now understood to be about 200
to 300 milligrams per kilogram of weight
which is about 20 grams per day for 180
pound person
so reminder that the treatment for
Spanish Flu in many areas was between 8
and 31 grams per day where the toxic
dose of aspirin is now interested to be
about 20 for a 180 pound person
yeah
um you know they don't the word lethal
isn't used here so I'm being a little
squidgy with my language because I
couldn't find I couldn't find the
precise language I was looking for but
um but yes I think so
so
um
Scott Tom Muller writes in this piece
this is why incredible caution should be
exercised around large departures from
tested and true medical practice and new
Pharma modalities and products aspirin
in 1918 was a new product relatively new
product
and his primary source is
this uh this paper called by a woman
named starko from 2009 called
salicylates and pandemic influenza
mortality
1918-1919 pharmacology pathology and
historic evidence it was published in
clinical infectious diseases
and is presented as a hypothesis which
is um pretty pretty fantastic and if you
want to show my screen I just have a
couple little sections to read from this
paper so again this is this is published
as hypothesis it's published under
um the title viewpoints uh Again by an
MD who appears to be an independent
researcher
uh in which she argues that it was
indeed the widespread use of aspirin as
a treatment for Spanish Flu which
actually explains
the mortality rate for Spanish Flu
here's a couple of quotes and sorry this
is going to jump around I'm going to try
to scroll slowly so I can show it to you
okay here we go all right
sorry guys
um
this one first a Confluence of events
created a perfect storm for widespread
salicylate aspirin toxicity the loss of
Bayers patent on aspirin in February
1917 allowed many manufacturers into the
lucrative aspirin Market
official recommendations for aspirin
therapy at toxic doses were preceded by
ignorance of the unusual non-linear
kinetics of salicylate which were
unknown until the 1960s which
predisposed to accumulation and toxicity
tins and bottles that contain no
warnings and few instructions and fear
of Spanish influenza and illness that
had been spreading like wildfire so
those are some of the
um we're going to stay on this for a
little bit those are some of the reasons
that she thinks we had a perfect storm
in 1918 for Spanish Flu to get treated
so aggressively and so wrongly and
dangerously and tragically as as the
hypothesis goes with for Spanish flu
four lines of evidence support the role
of salicylate intoxication in 1918
influenza mortality
pharmacokinetics mechanism of action
pathology and the Spate of official
recommendations for toxic regimens of
aspirin immediately before the October
1918 death Spike so I'm not going to go
through all of those all of those lines
of evidence but there's just one more
little piece I want to read to you I
think oh and just this the title of this
section here
aspirin advertisements in August 1918
and a series of official recommendations
for aspirin and September and early
October preceded the death Spike of
October 1918.
and so you have much like you do with
covet where
um you know the the big spikes after the
MRNA vaccines were introduced the big
spikes right as people were rushing to
get these these treatments which they
thought would free them from the fear
that had been inculcated in them in this
case you had a blitz campaign to
um to encourage everyone to buy aspirins
to treat with Aspirin doctors were
giving it between 8 and 31 grams per day
when 20 grams per day is now known to be
a potentially lethal dose and
um and people were able to buy it over
the counter in
um I'm actually not sure about that but
people were able to get it much more
freely than they had before because it
was no longer under patent
which
um it makes sense with the pathology
that was observed with Spanish Flu where
the dead had lungs that were saturated
soaking wet right and you know aspirin
famously thins the blood and the idea
that it was leaking into their
lungs is consistent with this so just to
to encapsulate this so far
um
the
the question is if the initial
supposition is right that respiratory
pathogens tend not to be that serious
they tend not to be that virulent
because in order to succeed they have to
keep you more or less on your feet then
what the heck happened with Spanish flu
that one was pretty damn virulent and it
had a very high case fatality rate and
now the question is could it have been
aspirin could it have been the insanely
high doses that were being given at the
time and the fear that stoked people
including doctors to use and to
prescribe these very very high doses and
when they weren't working to amp them up
the way we did with the respirator
pressures yeah the ventilator pressures
precisely and apparently
doctors military doctors were were early
early adopters of aspirin as treatment
and I
maybe there was some evidence some
places that what I've seen in my you
know relatively brief look so far is
that once you were on the aspirin is
going to be useful to treat Spanish Flu
Game uh at the point that your patients
started to get sicker the response was
almost always we'll give them more
aspirin which then actually accelerated
the demise of the patient yes and the
fact that this was happening in a
military context which is again very top
down right so you know whatever the high
ups are saying you know the high up
doctors in the military are saying
should be used is going to spread like
wildfire the point is that also Stokes
fear by giving the impression that it is
these young highly fit soldiers what the
heck kind of pathogen is this yes right
so the anomalies are
many surrounding 1918 and I would also
point out that just as you know every
death was counted as a coveted death
which amped our fear which caused us to
react with you know basically like a
panicked like a drowning person rather
than a rational person the idea that the
1918 flu was Haunting US during covet
fear of that flu caused us to behave
irrationally with respect to covid when
it emerged and frankly there's more
reason to be concerned about covid
because you know it's a you know it came
apparently from a lab but nonetheless it
does if either it's going to be able to
spread in which case it's going to abide
by at least some of the things that
limit the uh the the virulence of a
normal respiratory pathogen
and here we you know it goes every bad
policy and mandated them from above
right and I think you you said it but um
iatrogenic causes of death and illness
will be a hundred percent conflatable
with the illness itself the pathogen
itself being the cause of death and
illness because iatrogenic harm only
comes when you go to the medical
establishment for treatment of the thing
and so of all of the things that could
possibly be conflated this is this is
the easiest one to do and that you know
that doesn't mean that the conflation
was necessarily intentional right but if
a pathogen causes something and the
treatment of that something is far more
dangerous for you than the pathogen was
you you need to not be surprised at the
point that you have a hard time teasing
those two effects apart and the way to
tease those two effects apart is to look
at the different different Health Care
practices in places like New York versus
Delaware with regard to ventilators or
military bases versus cities with regard
to aspirin during Spanish flu right and
I think uh or you know or Sweden versus
uh yes I think I think Norway but I
don't know but Sweden versus some other
northern European country with regard to
effects of lockdowns and uh letting a
society be you know be as it is so you
know you look you look for the place
that did the different thing that you
think may have been causing the
iatrogenic harm and then you can begin
to see pattern and there will be those
who will say well
there's no RCT there's no randomized
control study on that randomized
controlled trial like of course there
can't be because that's not the way this
research could possibly work and that is
not a damning of the hypothesis or the
suggestion that it could be atrogenic
harm that is just the nature of the harm
that it causes you cannot do an RCT on
this so I will say before I was aware of
this argument on my last uh Joe Rogan
appearance I mentioned this possibility
I mentioned that I was in I was now
increasingly dwelling on the early use
of the ventilators
um and the fact that that would have
amped up the case the apparent case
fatality rate and caused us to react
ever more strongly and I worry that you
know in an environment
where behind the scenes
governmental authorities are actually
licensing themselves to let themselves
to shut down truth
right that they would also
um potentially who knows in what ways
they might be willing to cause panic in
order to get us to surrender
to their to their Authority yeah
there's just another couple of things
before we move on to our final segment
for today
um I as I said this paper is presented
as hypothesis it's got a lot of
suggestive suggestive evidence but I
looked at the I think it was a little
bit more than 100 papers that cite this
paper the starco 2009 paper that we've
been talking about and I find no
attempts successful or not just to
discredit it to discredit the argument
indeed I find and I you know I did not
look through all 100 papers at cited it
but a couple of the more recent papers
that site were interesting in different
ways
love it all in 2020
um used the argument by starko about the
use of aspirin as the cause of so much
of the death and destruction of the
Spanish Flu as a cautionary tale this is
again in 2020 they use they accept as
fact what Starker lays out as aspirin
having been a considerable cause of the
death from Spanish flu and use that to
argue against the use of
hydroxychloroquine for code
without as far as I can tell any any
reason for doing that but they say ah
this can happen therefore this is
happening here okay so that I found
um interesting and then there's another
paper when in fact the study that caused
hydroxychloroquine to be
um dropped from the list of possible
treatments had the dose turned up so
high that in fact it did toxify people
this very safe drug was given in such
high doses that it caused this effect
which uh
certainly raises some questions yes why
why given that unlike aspirin in 1918
hydroxychloroquine has been on the
market it's been in use for decades
already we know we know the the levels
you know not perfectly of course and it
will vary by individual but we have a
really good sense of what toxic levels
are so why would you have turned that
dial all the way up yep yep and so then
there was another paper that cites um
again the starco 2009 paper which argues
that aspirin widespread use of aspirin
to treat Spanish Flu was actually the
cause of many of the deaths during the
Spanish flu epidemic
short at all in 2018 this is before
covid is a highly cited more much more
actually is more highly cited than the
original starco paper
article called Back to the Future
Lessons Learned From the 1918 influenza
pandemic and it's published in Frontiers
in cellular and infection microbiology
so I thought this was promising but
fascinatingly this paper completely
ignores her conclusions while citing her
and I've seen that happen many many
times right so they don't respond to the
arguments in her paper at all they
simply cite her to say that aspirin was
used as treatment during the Spanish Flu
and I have to wonder why so they
basically got in both of these two
papers that I've just said cite starco
2009 and again I went looking to see
okay this is hypothesis let me see if
anyone has tried to debunk it right to
falsify it right and on full display in
both of these papers that are some of
the most recent most cited papers that
cite her
you have this reductionist hubristic
approach to humans that doesn't
understand anything about complex
systems the complex system that is the
human body that is our immune system
that is human society and you know it's
standards gosh it's something we've been
saying over and over and over again
welcome to complex systems why aren't
the researchers including the doctors
and the scientists who are publishing in
these medical and scientific journals
and who are presumably therefore helping
to set policy for the next time
why can't they understand complex
systems why are they working with this
arrogance and this reductionist model
that will continue to destroy people
yes
um they're doing it well I don't know I
think what we really need is a is a body
that is capable of investigating the
question because you know we are
persistently left with uh multiple
possibilities is this some new kind of
hyper virulent incompetence something
that exceeds all previous examples of
incompetence or do we have something
worse than that because it's really hard
to Fathom how you could do this much
wrong and be this consistent about it
right it's hard for incompetent people
to pull that off
um but this was uh you know
potentially something else truly
impressive if it's incompetence yeah
it's really it's a stunning level of it
it's it's uh you know connoisseur level
some of the most competent incompetence
that I've ever seen very well said thank
you
um I had two last points that I wanted
to make here one
um I was fascinated by this gatomalo
piece I also thought it was a very good
companion
for the piece that I wrote for unheard
boy I don't remember exactly when it was
but I wrote a piece about the question I
I had of course been about researching
biologist I handled many bats bare hands
um that was the way we handled them so
as not to injure them uh their wings are
very fragile
um and I had wondered at the point that
covet emerged I wondered well geez I was
handling wild bats and I you know
certainly took basic precautions but was
it possible that I was going to pick up
a virus
from a wild bat and I was going to be
patient zero in some massive pandemic
and I just got lucky and in considering
that question I realized that no in fact
I wasn't it's much harder for viruses to
LEAP from nature than we've been told we
have been sold the bill of goods that
has caused us to be much more frightened
of this possibility and in fact so
frightened that we apparently funded
research to study the viruses that we
thought or claimed or pretended could
have left out of Nature and then
turbocharged them to see what would
happen if they did right we this is a
self-inflicted wound and my point is no
I wasn't running a big risk of you know
spreading a pandemic by accident because
it's much harder for you know I could
have died of something but the point is
something in order to become a pandemic
has to LEAP into a person and then it
has to LEAP from person to person in
some way those are difficult
evolutionary steps for them to
accomplish so this is we talked about
this early on when we were first talking
about the possibility of lab leak back
in Spring of 2020 right the the the
rapid ability of this virus
um to move between people suggested that
it already had experience doing
something like that if not in people
than possibly in mink uh with uh what
was it the similar Ace II receptors
right uh mink uh human Airway tissue
humanized mice right all of these things
would have given at the training
essentially the lab playing the role of
the intermediate host which we've never
found because it probably doesn't exist
right um but anyway I thought okay so
gato Malo makes an excellent uh argument
that what happened is
um we spooked ourselves about a virus
that even though it is very destructive
was not likely to be that deadly by
virtue of the fact that it is a
respiratory virus and they abide by this
trade-off they have to if it had been a
super deadly virus it wouldn't have
spread around the world this way that's
right
um so that's one point and then my point
is and we also got scared by a bunch of
um ghost stories about how the next
virus was going to LEAP out of nature
any minute because humans are doing
something new and that's going to result
in some terrifying pandemic with an
extremely high fatality rate right also
not likely so those two things together
you know how how worried do we have to
be that a a virus is going to LEAP out
of Nature and have a huge case fatality
rate
um you know well if it's a respiratory
virus pretty low
and pretty low for things to jump
between species when we're talking about
things like bird flu we're actually
talking about things that do jump
between species regularly not something
that jumped from nature that had never
been seen in people before
let me just pick up I know you have one
more point but you said um with regard
to you know could you have were you
likely to become patient zero uh in in a
pandemic
um that you could have picked up from a
bat and then spread and you had a little
um asterisk there and said well you know
I could have gotten sick like I could
have come down with something and of
course you know one of your mentors
um did exactly that I believe no we
don't know what she died oh okay
um but but biologists do
um especially not so much with the kinds
of bats that you were working on because
you were working on making bats and you
weren't anywhere near caves right but
you know if you know bats do
um have respiratory viruses and being in
a cave where the air is famously not
refreshed and
um and is
um and a person working in a cave with a
bunch of bats May well pick up something
well they do it's not viruses the thing
that um that bad biologists sometimes
get is histoplasmosis which is a fungus
um but yes but it's but it's basically
another reason you know like should you
if the bats weren't at the cave you know
she'd be spending time in the cave or
outside of the cave you're better off
with regard to keeping clear of
respiratory infections being in fresh
air outside moving around right where
where there's a lot of airflow and you
know not in a you know a cave or a room
or care home or you know something else
where uh where whatever is floating
around you're probably going to inhale
it at some point yep yep no from the
point of view of you know there are
these three miners who appear to have
picked up something uh cove-like prior
to the ancestor of SARS Kobe 2
potentially having been taken into the
lab in Wuhan who died at but they didn't
transmit it to anybody right and frankly
the exposure level needed for them to
get sick was apparently incredibly high
they were working uh taking guano out of
an old mine and so the point is they
were you know knee-deep in a highly
Dusty destructive environment of the
lungs they picked up this uh disease and
did not transmit it right so the point
is getting something from nature is
possible transmitting it is unlikely to
other people unless there's some path
for that to happen
okay the last point I wanted to make is
we have said here
we have bridled when people have accused
us of uh quote unquote killing people by
discussing reasons to be concerned about
things like the safety of mRNA
transfection agents
which makes no sense at multiple levels
for one thing nobody seems particularly
eager to give us credit for having saved
people given that these transfection
agents appear to be dangerous right they
don't want to give us any credit they
just want to say you're killing people
by raising hesitancy when in fact
hesitancy may have been life-saving but
my point is I don't want credit for
saving people I don't want to be accused
of killing people I want the recognition
that the conversation saves people that
you can disagree with us and you may be
wrong and we may be right that doesn't
make us the Lifesavers and you The
Killers the point is an honest
participation in a conversation about
what is true amongst people who have
something reasonable to contribute
everybody is contributing to the thing
that saves lives right
on the flip side
were you a governmental official who
decided that it would be okay to pollute
the stream of information by pretending
that people who have died from uh abuse
of a ventilator are actually deaths due
to covid right pretending that a death
of you know a child is equivalent to the
death of somebody in their 80s people
who have not only polluted the
information stream but son saw fit to
silence those who were trying to unspin
their story right those people actually
did Kill folks right they were not
participating in a collective effort to
figure out what was true so that we
could lose fewer lives so that we could
you know protect people who were in a
position to be protected they did
exactly the opposite they blinded us
that's what they did they intentionally
blinded us and then they demonized Us by
claiming that even if we were saying
true things if they went in the
direction making you distrust vaccines
or your government for mandating them
that you were a terrorist right that is
the kind of diabolical stuff that we
have been dealing with and it is time
for everybody to wake up a government
that could do that to you cannot be
trusted and it must be cleared of people
who participated in that and it must be
restored to protecting the basic
principles that still apply as much as
they did when the founders outlined them
it's a perfect segue
to our last section
Theologian Paul tillich brought words of
warnings warning and passion to the
German people during World War II we're
going to share some of those words here
today this week librarian Keith waddle
who is a frequent listener of Dark Horse
sent us one of tillage's short essays
that was broadcast By Radio into Nazi
Germany
and I want to give you a little bit of
background on tillage first and then
read a couple of short excerpts from one
of his radio broadcasts
so he was born till it was born in 1886
near Berlin he was a German soldier
during World War One he was acting as a
Chaplain at that time but that didn't
protect him from seeing he was he was on
the front lines he was in foxholes he
was he saw he saw hell he was he was in
the trenches and he bury his best friend
I don't know that I think I read that
sounds plausible
um after the war among other things he
became a professor of philosophy at the
University of Frankfurt and he was the
opposite of Stuffy he was socializing he
was dancing he was womanizing much to
the Chagrin of his wife uh he was sort
of a bomb Viva uh he left Germany for
the United States as the Third Reich
ascended and continued his life there in
fact Brett who has been a photographer
all of his life has this uh wonderful
book Jump by the philosopher philosopher
photographer I don't know maybe he was a
photographic philosopher a photographer
Philip Houseman and he's just got a lot
of famous people jumping in it and
including Nixon and the pope and Marilyn
Monroe and um here we have uh Dr Paul
tillich right there I did not know that
yeah I didn't know that either until
this morning so um he's he's jumping as
are all of the people in this in this
book of
um of philosophical photographs
um so he was in he was in the U.S
but uh he was watching from afar
got so much fur in our world
um he was watching that may be a local
phenomenon yes I think so
um he was watching from afar as uh as
the Third Reich was continued to ascend
and
from March 1942 to Mar to May of 1944 he
recorded 112 addresses in German for
secret broadcasts by voice of America
which fell under the control of the U.S
office of War information and his aim
was and I'm quoting here from
um a book against the Third Reich
Tilly's aim with these radio broadcasts
was to divide the will of his German
listeners from the Mania of their Nazi
rulers and to Spur people in strategic
positions to muster the necessary
courage to stand against the terrorizing
police state of Nazism
and I will just I will remind us that it
is very easy to look back to the 1940s
and feel righteous and like everyone
would have seen what was going on but we
can be quite sure given we have lived
through in the last three years that the
vast majority of people don't see it
when it happens and uh the radio
broadcasts
that he made these 112 broadcasts that
he made with the help of Voice of
America and the US government are
collected into a book this book called
against the Third Reich Paul tillage's
wartime radio broadcasts into Nazi
Germany and the one I'm going to read a
few excerpts from is called the
Intelligentsia and Germany's conquest
and it was originally broadcast on
September 4th 1942 and I can show my
screen if you like although it's going
to be so small hold on a second
um that I'm actually going to read from
the paper here
um so okay
um I'm just gonna read the first two
paragraphs and then
um in the last one
my German friends
wrote Paul tillich today I want to speak
to a group of people that is perhaps
small in its supporting Circle but great
in its consequences and its effects I
mean the bearers of the scholarly work
of art and literature of music and
public discourse
even if they were a hundred thousand
they would be few in proportion to the
millions of German people
but among these millions there is no one
who is not influenced in any way by this
group even if only in the language that
he speaks and the technology that he
uses
for this reason the leaders of the
intellectual life of a Nation are
infinitely important for its destiny
this group of intellectually leading
Germans is more responsible for the
tragedy of Germany and The Misfortune
that it has brought on the world and
itself and the masses of the nation are
and nearly as responsible as that small
stratum of landed Proprietors and large
entrepreneurs who handed over weapons
and capital to national socialism
because they trembled in the face of
social reorganization
why did a great portion of the German
Scholars writers and artists make common
cause with the forces of reaction which
held the stirrups for the present regime
many will say what many of these
stirrupholders are saying today we did
not know that the writer whom we helped
with the saddle would ride the German
nation in many nations with it into the
abyss we were an error and we have made
amends for that
such an admission is certainly valuable
and more promising for the future than
the attitude of those who even today
when the abyss has already become
visible pronounce their attitude at that
time to be correct
and yet the admission of error is not
enough
one must understand how the error could
come about what routes it had and one
must exterminate these roots in order
that new errors and new harm may not
grow forth from them
what are the roots from which one can
account for the breakdown of the German
intellectual leaders how can they be
exterminated and what mission does an
intellectual bearing stratum have in the
Reconstruction of Germany every thinking
German should put this question to
himself above all those who rank
themselves among the bearers of
intellectual life
wow and then we're going to have one
more but maybe we talk about that before
we share the
yeah that's that's incredible
um I must say I feel like sending it to
Sam Harris I think you might appreciate
it I'd hope he'd appreciate it but um
anyway yeah that's um extremely powerful
and I love the uh the point he makes
about the responsibility that these
people have the disproportionate
responsibility and their
disproportionate failure and its
implication for uh what did he say
holding the stirrups for the new regime
holding the stair-ups for the new regime
yeah yes the people who would have us
believe that they are the intellectual
lifeblood of the country and are to be
trusted
and whatever conclusions they come to
you too can come to those conclusions
they're holding the stirrups for the
Masters who do not have your best
interests at heart
and anyone who was telling you
that you should not try to understand
for yourself but simply accept
the authoritative conclusions of others
uh when when you have seen with your own
eyes how reliably the authoritative
conclusions of others have been wrong
they also do not have your best
interests at heart regardless of whether
or not they are merely confused or are
actually trying to hurt you it doesn't
matter don't listen to them don't listen
to them
one sentence in the middle of this essay
which is extraordinary I recommend it
the unveiling of the truth is not
pleasant to those who have power and
misuse this power at the expense of
others for this reason they fear the
intellect and seek either to wipe out
its bearers or what is more important in
the long run to buy them and to place
them in their service
okay and one more just the last
paragraph of this piece same piece
originally broadcast
um
by Paul tillich with the help of the U.S
government from America where he was by
then living into Nazi Germany in just
looking for the dates and the of the
broadcast uh was
uh September 4th 1942.
final paragraph
I've spoken today in the first place to
the bearers of the intellect the
scholars and writers the artists and
orators but the intellectuals of every
nation not only form the nation but are
also formed by it
and for this reason I call out to the
German Nation do not consent any longer
to your philosophers and authors
Conjuring up a world that is not yours
and that leaves you in your misery
demand intelligence from them that is in
fact intelligence that does not glorify
a wicked reality but unveils and unmasks
the roots of this reality
the intellect that seeks Anew that sees
a new reality and builds in partnership
with you the mind that says what you
feel and thinks what you hope
allow the old feeble mind to Decay
Behind the Walls
Behind the Walls of the Ruger culture
board and make room for the new mind
that changes reality
extremely powerful
I know
that there are many
uh in America today both among the class
who consider ourselves intellectuals and
people who don't consider themselves
intellectuals although frankly the
distinction uh is one that in most cases
I think it's without a difference
uh but to the degree that tillich was
making a distinction it's important in
in thinking about this essay
there are so many people who are not
confused and the ways that they got
there are variable
but the people that we hear from and
there are a lot of them
who say
I had something in my gut
I thought that there wasn't something
right I started to see this and then
this and then this and I couldn't make
sense of why I was supposed to start
believing them after it was clear that
they had at least been wrong if hadn't
if not had been lying to me so far
thank you for having the conversations
that modeled intelligent conversation
again
in terms of
raising awareness of where the
inconsistencies were where the bodies
were buried why the science couldn't
possibly have said what they were
telling us the science said and frankly
being
if maybe most of all just staunch in our
defensive science of actual science not
the science in follow the science not
the science that fauci claims to embody
that's not science what we need what we
need to be a functioning Society to have
any chance of moving forward into the
middle of this Century much less the
next one is actually have people who
understand what science is are willing
to do it even when the results of it
produce something that you look at and
go God
I wish that weren't true
but if it is
let's go let's figure it out let's
figure out what to do next pretending
that what is true isn't serves no one in
the long run
yeah we have a situation where
our governments or whatever has captured
them is demonizing the very people that
we need to listen to but it is also
doing so in an era where we have a new
kind of
Pirate Radio you know where we have
Glenn Greenwald we have Snowden we have
Russell Brand we have Joe Rogan we have
Woody Harrelson we have Bobby Kennedy Jr
we have all of these voices who are you
know each of them taking from their own
uh
discipline
and
uh standing up courageously John
Campbell all of these people are telling
us something that we need to know and uh
it's like
it's like a society in Exile
and I think it is time that we lean into
it and figure out how the adults are
going to you know write the ship of
state and return us to uh
a place where we can you know again
fight over how it is we can achieve the
values that we all agree on
absolutely
all right all right I think we're there
for the week
um we will not be doing a q a today
encourage you to go check out Natural
Selections
find us at our patreons perhaps we will
be back here same time next week and
then 30 Pacific time on Saturday and
next week we will be following that with
a q a so if you were um if you have been
holding on to a question for a while
you can ask it them or you can go into
my patreon
and find an opportunity soon to ask a
question in advance for that private q a
which is a lot of fun
so until we see you next
be good to the ones you love eat good
food
be well everyone